[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 129 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
MARK MANDEL: Very well.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
know, it's funny.
I talked to somebody
recently on our team.
And they were like, I listened
to one of your podcasts,
and it was when
you both were sick.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was thinking,
that's right.
Mark is finally well.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: It took
you a really long time.
MARK MANDEL: It did.
It did.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyways,
so Mark, this week we're
going to be talking
with Mandy Waite, who
is on our team and our
Developer Relations team.
And she runs one of the groups.
And she talks to us all
about developer relations,
and what it is, and
how to think about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, super interesting chat.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
as always, we always
start with the cool
thing of the week.
And we end with our
question of the week.
And the question for this
week is that, on May 25,
as some of you may be aware,
especially from all the privacy
notices that you might
be getting in your inbox,
GDPR has gone into effect.
And so we wanted to touch on
that briefly in terms of Google
Cloud Platform and what that
means for our group and Google
Cloud Platform.
So we will do that at the end.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And we also are coming out
of the Memorial weekend
for this podcast.
So hopefully, everybody's
having a nice break,
or has had a nice break.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Awesome.
So let's get stuck into our
cool things of the week.
This one, I like a lot.
This is really neat.
Basically, we have a blog post,
an article, and documentation,
and stuff you can play
with for better cost
controls with
Google Cloud Billing
programmatic notifications.
Short answer being,
if you've ever
been thinking, what happens
if my costs just suddenly
skyrocket and I don't
happen to notice them?
That would be bad.
I would not appreciate
that on Google Cloud.
So what we can do now is set
up programmatic notifications
for cost control
on Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is good.
This is really important.
MARK MANDEL: It's really cool.
So right now, it's set up
so that basically, a Pub/Sub
notification occurs.
But we have examples set up so
that you can go and read them.
We'll put the links
in the show notes.
Basically, to fire off a Cloud
function which could then
do things like send a
notification to Slack,
possibly send you an email.
You could even do stuff
like just turn off billing
or possibly turn off certain
resources within your project
to help slow down
the amount of cost
that you're having,
depending on what it is
that you're building.
Really, the world's your oyster.
But it is really
cool now that you
have this sort of warning
system in place and/or
something you might want to
automatically do actions on to.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
Yeah, the post
helps you understand
what you can do to set up
these types of notifications
and makes it easy for
you, which is good
because I agree with you.
It's important for us to
have a way to monitor and not
go over budget.
OK, so the other cool
thing of the week
is one of our
colleagues, Gabe Weiss,
has written about a cool
IoT project he worked on,
which was in conjunction
with Firebase.
And so he wanted to--
he's a musician on the side.
And there's a sound room that
he wanted to be able to have
an understanding of when it's
available and when it isn't.
So he built out an IoT
device using a Raspberry Pi
and Passive Infrared sensor
to detect motion and determine
when the room is in use.
And he was doing this
with a motion sensor
to avoid capturing sound or
capturing video in that room,
but to definitely
detect, is it in use
and how often is it in use?
And he shows how to build that
out with the actual IoT device,
as well as combine it with
Firebase to track the data
itself.
So you should check
out the blog posts
and see if you want to play
around with the motion detector
yourself.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Another fun thing.
Alexi, who is on
our team as well--
we've mentioned him before--
he does a "This Week in Google
Cloud Platform" blog post.
One of the things out
of that that I thought
was particularly interesting--
recent I/O attendees
were able to complete in-person
codelabs at the event.
But those codelabs are
actually available as well.
There's 25-plus updated Cloud
Codelabs that you can get.
We'll put the link
in the show notes.
It's g.co/io/codelabs.
If you click on
the Cloud category,
you can get the Cloud ones.
But all the other ones
are there as well.
Also, we'll put a link in
there that there's also
the complete list of
free Cloud Codelabs.
They remain available as well.
G.co/codelabs/cloud--
those are all available.
So if you're looking
for some free training
or some free how-tos on how to
build stuff on Cloud, on Google
Cloud specifically, we'll put
those links in the show notes,
and you can have a go.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And the last thing
we're going to mention
is that there is a
Kubernetes podcast,
if you haven't noticed--
one that is explicitly
about Kubernetes.
And that's being run by
Adam Glick and Craig Box.
And we'll put the link
in the show notes.
But they have been releasing
podcasts every week
so far for the last month.
On Tuesday is when
they usually release.
And so far, we had
Paris Pittman, a couple
months ago now, come on.
And that was their first guest.
And since then, they've touched
on kubeflow, and gVisor,
and Stackdriver,
Kubernetes Monitoring.
So check this out if you're
looking for more information
on Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: It's a really
hard domain to remember.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is.
MARK MANDEL: It's
kubernetespodcast.com.
It's that simple.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
It'll be all your
things Kubernetes.
We'll still keep talking
about Kubernetes, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
I'm on the show.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Because Mark's here.
But if you want more, if
this isn't enough for you,
you will have another
avenue to check out.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, shall we go
chat with Mandy then?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I think it's time.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This week's podcast,
we are thrilled to have
with us Mandy Waite, who's
a manager on the DevRel team.
And Mandy, thanks
for joining us.
MANDY WAITE: Thank
you for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm glad our
schedules finally aligned.
Now that we have
you here, can you
tell the people who are
listening a little bit
about who you are, what you do?
MANDY WAITE: So my
name is Mandy Waite.
I am Developer Advocate.
I'm not actually a
manager of that currently.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google Cloud.
I'm on a team of infrastructure
and operations advocates,
working with a wide variety of
communities, such as DevOps,
SRE, Cloud-native,
Cloud-native Ops--
potentially Security and
Networking in the future.
We're still growing
the team, so we're
focused very much on DevOps
and Cloud-native currently.
I've been around Google
for nearly eight years now.
I came from Sun
Microsystems where
I used to do a similar
role, but which
was much more marketing
aligned, trying to get
people to adopt our stuff.
And I got a job with
Google working on AdWords
as a Developer Advocate.
That was interesting,
an extremely great
technical challenge, because
the API, the AdWords API,
is extremely complicated.
And it's a lot of fun.
And it has a scale.
And understanding that was
really, really useful to me.
The kind of background I
had was scaling systems,
and scaling APIs was new to me.
But it had very much the
same kind of similar problems
that I've been facing
in the past with Sun.
And then I moved to Cloud
in 2012, at the end of 2012.
And I've been on
Cloud ever since.
And we've grown from a small
team of people, a mix of roles
before, to a small team
of Developer Advocates,
to a team of a number
of areas over time.
And I think it's 46.
So we have a large team now.
We generally no longer call
ourselves Developer Advocates.
We've much more
aligned with being
advocates, or Cloud Advocates.
On a day, we do Developer
Advocacy as well.
For me, it's much more around
not really covering developers
anymore.
It's more about talking
to other communities,
and ones that are very,
very important to us when
it comes to making sure
that we have the best
possible products.
And that would be the DevOps
community, Cloud-native,
Cloud-native
Operations communities.
SRE is a great story.
Lots of people are starting
to look at doing SRE--
security for the
future, probably
security across the board,
across all different aspects
of technology.
So that's what we're
doing currently.
As I say, I manage a team.
I have about 10 people
in my team, currently.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
your team focuses on--
you were saying-- you're on
infrastructure and operations,
right?
MANDY WAITE: Infrastructure,
operations, yeah.
It's a very general term.
I'm not sure if
it's the best term,
but it's the one we landed on.
I originally called it
Operations and Infrastructure.
But somehow, it
got turned around.
I'm not sure why, but I don't
think it really matters.
It could be the DevOps team or
the DevOps Cloud-native team,
but Infrastructure
and Operations
seems to cover it more.
It's definitely not
developer-centric.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm going to
ask you the hard question then.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
MARK MANDEL: How do you
define developer relations?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
So interesting question.
To be honest, I mean,
the fact that we
work with other communities
other than developers
gives us an
interesting challenge,
because some
umbrella term that we
can use to reference
all of these communities
that we work with--
developer community, the DevOps
community, the Data Science
community-- there is no
really good umbrella term.
And we tend to fall back
on technical communities
as being the umbrella term,
but it's not a good one.
We're still fundamentally
developer relations,
but we've just really kind of
overloaded the term "developer"
to mean all of these
other communities as well.
And so Developer Relations
is actually making sure
that we have the best possible
products and the best possible
experience for people using
the products as possible
and also making sure that
we communicate what we have,
take our narratives and
our messages on the road
and show them to
people, help them
understand how they can
solve their problems
with our products.
Because that's
extremely important.
But not forcing products down
people's throats and saying,
hey, we have this thing.
You should use this.
It's not around giving
people product pictures,
it's about talking
about how we can solve
problems using our technology.
And often, that's a
case of meeting people
where they are when you
have something like Cloud,
because that involves
using tooling
that they're familiar with
already with our Cloud product.
So if they're using
something like Jenkins
to do build pipelines
and such, like CI/CD,
then we want Jenkins
to work really well.
And a great example of that
would be Infrastructure
as Code, that kind of thing--
having people making
sure they use Share
from Puppet and Terraform--
and that those things
work perfectly well
with our Cloud Platform.
There is also an aspect of
being opinionated as well--
say like, Google
do things this way.
And this is what we've
been doing with Kubernetes
for a long time.
So four years ago, we
saw this with Kubernetes.
It was new to us,
apart from the fact
that we knew how things
worked internally
at Google, with Borg.
And I think you've had John
[? Wilkes ?] talking about Borg
before.
Borg was really, really
interesting to many of us.
And taking that message out
on the road to show people,
hey, have you ever
considered doing it this way?
It was in the back end of
the container revolution.
And my message back
then was very much, hey,
I have all of these containers.
Now what do I do with them?
And Kubernets was
the solution to that.
It was highly opinionated,
but it was also a new paradigm
as well.
And I think people have
adopted it at scale.
And I think it's a really
good inflection curve showing
adoption of Kubernetes.
And I'd like to see
more of that happening.
But being opinionated
about something,
you have to be careful with it.
Because you can't
always change the way
people feel about something.
Meeting people where they
are is very, very important.
But if you have a
better way, then you
should be showing them
how they can be successful
doing it that way,
but without dismissing
what they're doing
currently and making
it seem like what they're
doing may be trivial
compared to what we're doing.
"Build it like Google"
might be a great message,
but we have to be respectful
of the fact that people build
things their own way currently.
And if this helps them and
solves some of their problems
for them, then that's great.
And we can take
those messages out,
and people will listen to them.
But we have to meet
people where they are
and keep your opinionation
a little bit more lower key.
MELANIE WARRICK: So you
were saying about how
this being Developer Relations.
What comprises a
Developer Relations?
MANDY WAITE: What comprises
I got people.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, so
part of the reason I'm asking
is Mark and I are officially
Developer Advocates.
And I know we have a
number of different roles
within the team.
And so I'm basically
setting this up
to say, hey, what are
some of the roles, what
are some of the makeup of
the teams that we have?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
I don't think I
was being flippant
by saying people as
well, because I think
it's very important that
the people aspect of it
is so massively
important to this role.
It is very much about
working with people
and being to communicate
with them, to be
able to understand their needs.
Empathy is a huge word,
a word that we use a lot.
Another word that is
really important is trust.
So trust and empathy are
very much people things
and not related to technology
in any meaningful way.
And I think it's probably
very easy to be in technology
and not have a lot of trust
and not have a lot of empathy.
And I think one of
the keys to being
successful in
Developer Relations
is being able to
have those skills--
not necessarily develop them.
I think you can develop empathy.
I always go back
to something I saw
when I was working with
a TV rental company
back in the UK a long, long time
ago, when I was 16 years old.
And they used to have
a sign on the wall
next to the reception
area saying, "Be Sincere."
And I've always said,
you can't be sincere.
You either are or you aren't.
And I think there's some
of that with empathy.
Empathy is something you
potentially can develop,
but it is deep.
It is fundamental.
You can't make people think
you have empathy for them.
You either do or you don't.
And I think having empathy
is something that I see
across the whole of the team.
And I think that's really,
really important for us.
And the trust part of it
is also implicit, also.
MARK MANDEL: So what benefits
does Google Cloud get out
of the relationship that it has
with its Developer Relations
team?
Why do we even exist?
MANDY WAITE: Yes.
I began 20 years,
probably, doing this work.
People have always known we
were very important and not
really quite known why
or been prepared to take
the risk of not having DevRel.
Back at Sun
Microsystems, we used
to be moved from
software organizations
to marketing organizations
because people
knew that we were absolutely
necessary, but not quite sure
where we fitted into
the organization.
So why do we have DevRel?
Well, I actually
asked this question
to some people a
couple of years ago.
We were doing some
strategizing around things.
And I asked the
question, what would
happen if there was no DevRel?
And the answer was very much,
we would have worse products.
We would have worse
developer experiences.
And I said, I thought the answer
was that the product teams
would create their own DevRel.
It was an essential
role within the team.
We would need a
product team to have
some kind of DevRel function.
Some PMs, many PMs,
thought that they
have a good handle on
what customers are doing
and such like.
Not all of them feel very
close to their actual community
of users.
Could be, in this case,
the DevOps community
in my team, or the
developer community.
And they know that they
need to go out and get
that information.
They also need to
know that they need
to take their messages
out and show people
how they can be successful
with those products
that they're building.
So they would fundamentally
build their own DevRel team.
And if you look at that
scale across a large number
of products-- and going
back to when I started,
it was things like AdWords,
Web, Chrome, Android--
you would have lots of different
DevRel functions growing up
in parallel.
And commonalities,
scale, it would
make it sensible to
pull them all out
and put them together
in one place.
I would argue that
there are always
problems around doing
DevRel in a cookie cutter
way for a specific product.
It needs to be different in
kind for each different product.
I think that's extremely
important to understand.
And it also depends
where a product
is in its product lifecycle.
It depends on your
audience as well.
So those considerations
are important.
But I think having
the DevRel team,
we can benefit from
large scale programs.
The kind of mentality and the
mindset of people that we hire
gives us a huge
edge when it comes
to doing DevRel, as opposed to
having a product team building
their own team.
So I think that's why we
have DevRel currently.
Yeah.
I think I'll leave
it at that because I
know one of the next questions
you're going to ask me about,
how we measure it, which
is going to be interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, well,
OK, how do you measure it?
What are ways that you can
determine it's impactful?
MANDY WAITE: I've given
this a lot of thought,
a lot of thought over the years.
I think there is always
consequences of the work
that we do-- the
number of people
who watch a video,
the length of time
that they watch the video,
the amount of engagement they
have with the things
that we produce.
And they could be looking
at a meeting post, or even
a blog post.
Often, those things are very
easy to measure and capture.
I think there is a danger
around having a goal
around those numbers, always.
I don't think it's a good thing
to have a goal around a number,
to say we should have 1 million
video views within Q1 or Q2.
I don't think that's a
very good way of doing it,
but it is a good metric.
And so if you look at
the work that you do
and the things that
you do, some metrics
are going to bubble out of that.
And you can push
them up to people.
But they shouldn't be the
reason why you're doing it.
So the reason you
would do a video series
was to get important
information out to people
or to drive some strategic
goal that you really care about
and that you've agreed
with the product teams.
And ultimately, the metrics
will drop out of that.
And you can report up on them.
And you can say, we did 500
events or 600 events last year.
We did 150 videos, and
we had x number of views,
and x number of in-person
outreach was done.
But I don't think
they're the numbers
that we should be driving.
I think one thing--
this is a little
bit dangerous, but I
think it's interesting to
think about this more-- is
that products tend to
have a graph of adoption,
or usage, utilization,
or efficacy, usefulness,
and that kind of thing.
And those graphs-- you
naturally want them
to go off and to the right.
Probably not linearly.
You'd like exponential
growth, if possible.
But I think your products are
going up and to the right,
and you have a DevRel
function there,
I think that shows that your
DevRel function is working
and doing things correctly.
You might be tempted
to say, well, just
take my DevRel function
away and see if it flattens.
But you're not going
to want to do that.
So there is always that danger.
You're not quite sure.
You can't necessarily
attribute the work
that DevRel does to go up
and to your right curve.
But I think it's
important to understand
it is a fundamental part of
all of your process of building
a product and
bringing it to market,
is that you have a DevRel
function that's ultimately
driving the product to be
better, based on people's
feedback, and that you're
showing people how to use it
and making sure people
are aware of it.
I think awareness is a
great thing, but awareness
is so difficult.
It's so difficult.
It still seems to
me that there's
a large number of
people out there,
a large percentage of
people-- not a number,
a large percentage of people
there-- that have not heard
about Google Cloud products.
And that seems strange,
considering the amount of work
that we've done.
But I just think that there
are a large number of people
out there.
And I think we have
to be aware of that.
And a lot of people
work in environments
where they don't get exposed to
all of these things very much,
and so maybe they don't
know of it because of that.
I'd like everybody to
know about our products
and how to be successful
with those products.
I'd like to be getting
feedback from everybody
so that we can bring that
back to the product teams
and make our products better.
I don't know how
we can reach that,
but I think we probably need
to continue growing DevRel
as the product teams grow.
I think we lag
behind a little bit.
As the products grow,
DevRel is always
a little bit behind
the curve when
it comes to adding more people.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
in terms of impact,
what are some of the
activities you've seen
that have had the most impact?
MANDY WAITE: That's a
really good question.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you
didn't give that one to me.
[LAUGHTER]
MANDY WAITE: You're right.
That is a good question.
And I think people do
things in different ways.
I think the great thing
about our DevRel team
is there is no cookie
cutter approach to doing it.
We do it differently.
We do it based on our own
skills, our own experiences,
the things that we're good at.
We do it based on our own
products in our own communities
that we're trying to reach and
our own goals and strategies
as well.
So I see lots of
different things and lots
of different success stories.
I think having a
podcast is a great idea.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MANDY WAITE: So whoever came
up with that idea should be--
MELANIE WARRICK:
It was all Mark.
MARK MANDEL: I have
no idea who that was.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Maybe it was your dog.
[DOG BARKS]
MARK MANDEL: It was
Francisco's idea.
I'll give it to him.
MANDY WAITE: But we got
very good at doing videos.
And we felt in
the past two years
ago that we weren't very
good at doing videos.
And now we're much
better at doing videos.
We get a lot of attention
from our videos--
very short, very succinct,
and very to-the-point.
We socialize them very well,
and we get lots of views.
And I think that's
really important.
That's really impactful.
I think that for
open source projects,
which is really a new thing
around doing advocacy for--
or DevRel for, generally,
I won't singular advocacy,
but just DevRel generally--
is that it's a different kind
of way of doing things.
And I look at somebody
like [? Yonda Doken ?]
on my team, who's
working on open sensors,
and she's really involved
in the community.
She was a [INAUDIBLE]
on the community.
She's been doing lots of
contributions to that.
But she understands
exactly what the mission is
and what the goal is.
And she understands the
community and their needs.
And she understands what she
would like to get out of it.
And she's doing a
different kind of DevRel
there with open sensors.
So that's another
different way of doing it
and another different
way of being successful.
So I think it's really a
case of constantly exploring
and constantly adapting.
I have this goal.
I want to achieve
this, which may be
I want to grow
adoption of BigQuery--
constantly thinking about
new ways of doing it.
Maybe going on Reddit and
getting millions and billions
of people to actually talk
about your product, which
somebody on our team does.
MARK MANDEL: Philippe.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, Philippe.
So yeah, so I think there's lots
of great things that people do.
And I'm just hoping that
there's more innovation.
Because you look at
it, and you think,
we've done all of
the DevRel we can,
all the different
ways of doing DevRel.
But then somebody's going to
come up with something new.
Oh, actually [INAUDIBLE] is
currently doing live stream
coding--
Twitch for DevRel, effectively.
And I really like that.
And I think that's
going to be a new model.
[INAUDIBLE] a different
way of thinking.
I tend to think that
people will change
as they grow with technology.
The way people think
about things is probably
different than the way I
used to think about them when
I was young.
Because just technology
is there and ever present.
And I think live streaming
seems to be a really big deal
for people nowadays.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
Mark is doing that.
And so is Holden,
actually, at this time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There's a few of us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Chris
[INAUDIBLE] on the Go team.
[INAUDIBLE]
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.
Yeah.
So live stream is a new one.
So these are the
things we wouldn't
have predicted a while back.
I'm hoping that
next year, there'll
be another really great
innovative way of actually
doing this kind of
developer relations
and getting the
message out to people.
MELANIE WARRICK: Maybe
something with IoT.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So on a practical note--
and you were talking
about this as well,
how tailoring the
DevRel experience
for different communities
and different groups.
You run the Infrastructure
and Ops group, which
is a very different community,
say, than maybe the wider tech
community.
How have you seen basically
the approach for DevRel
in that space be different
from, say, other communities
that you've worked in?
MANDY WAITE: I think the DevOps
community have a different need
from the more general
developer community.
I kind of struggle
with saying that
at times, because I think
we've grown up with developers.
We've been in
developer relations
for 10 years, 11 years or so.
And it's easy to think that
developers and DevOps are
different fundamentally,
that the way we should do
messaging to them is different.
I think, at the moment, we don't
have very many people doing
developer relations for DevOps.
And so I think the
key here is to look
to hire people who are
practitioners, people who
actually come from
that community,
are part of that community,
and bring them onto the team,
and have them advocate on
behalf of that community
to our product teams, and
also understand their needs
and help them solve
their problems,
because the problems
that are community
have are exactly
the same problems
that they've had up till now.
And so I think that's
really, really important.
And I'm going to
follow up on that.
I'm just going to just break
the question a little bit.
I often find myself
drawing to people
on a whiteboard something
called a Treynor curve.
So Ben Treynor has this curve.
Ben Treynor is the guy who
invented SRE at Google.
And we have this Treynor curve
about how people's skills
change over time.
And I constantly
draw this picture
whereby a practitioner would
have core practitioners skills,
and maybe not so much advocacy
skills at the time they start,
and that their practitioner
skills would weigh in over time
and their advocacy
skills would improve.
And so I have my
own Treynor curve
whereby advocacy skills are now
much better than practitioner
skills.
And I think, at times,
you need to kick energy
back into that to say,
hey, you need to go back
to being a practitioner again.
It may well be that they
feel comfortable in it.
They're really on it, and they
actually know what's going on.
But I think from
time to time, you
need to step back and say, OK,
what is my community doing?
Let me go back and be
one of them for a while.
And I'd like to see
us do more of that
when it comes to practitioners.
So I think that's
really, really helpful--
having practitioners and keeping
those practitioner skills.
And I think it's also possible
to pivot to a practitioner role
as well.
And I think we have an
evidence of that on my team
currently when it
comes to security,
which Jane is doing as well.
And I think that's really,
really interesting.
I think there's also a lot
of space for more generalists
to grow up into
that space as well,
and to learn from
the practitioners,
and to become
practitioners as well.
So having more senior
people as practitioners,
but having more junior
people as the people who
learn from them, take their
messages on the road, maybe not
have the same kind
of recognition
as they do, but can help
with content, and videos,
and such like.
And I think those people
are really, really key to it
as well, because there are
not that many practitioners
in the world.
And so if you want to have
a reasonably large team
and good coverage,
then you're probably
not going to be able to do that
just by hiring practitioners.
So the other thing to
get from practitioners--
I had this conversation
with [INAUDIBLE] recently
about trust versus credibility.
And I do agree.
Trust is extremely important.
We need people to
trust our advocates
when they talk to them--
I know this person, I trust
what they're telling me.
And at the same time, our
Product Team stakeholders,
as well, should trust
them and trust them
when they bring stories
and feedback back
to the product teams
that say, maybe
you should do it this way.
They trust that person's
view, and they give it
due consideration.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know
trust, in particular,
is very valuable when you
can give them a perspective,
and it's not necessarily being
driven by the product itself.
It's being
specifically driven by,
this is what I know
about the space.
This is what I'm able to bring
to the table about the space.
Yeah.
So when I was asking earlier
before about developer
relations at Google
and what that
looked like, a little part of
why I had led down the path
to that question was I hear
"develoepr evangelists"
as a term that's
constantly intermixed
with "developer advocate."
So I'm curious what
your perspective is
on these two terms,
and how they relate,
and how they don't relate.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
Another really
interesting question.
I think we're a large company.
We have a large
developer relations team.
It's very easy for us to kind of
be very specific about what we
do when it comes to our role.
We can shape the role to
be what it needs to be.
And so let's go back
a bit, take one step.
It's bidirectional,
our role as advocates.
It's doing evangelism
effectively, talking to people.
What I think it's a
different kind of evangelism.
It's much more like
sitting down with people
and holding their hands and
talking them through things,
learning from them and having
them learn from you as you
talk them through how
you can potentially
solve their problems.
At that point, you
might learn things
that you didn't know about
the product and how it works,
and which you can bring feedback
back to the product teams.
So it's not really
fundamentally evangelism,
although there is a lot of that.
Going to events
and doing outreach
is very much a
form of evangelism.
And at the other end,
there's this kind
of influence on the product,
and bringing feedback back,
and making cases, writing what
we call friction logs, which
are things that detail
somebody's interactions
with our product and
some of the problems
that they may have had,
raising bugs, driving fixes,
showing people
what kind of impact
is likely to be achieved through
addressing a particular issue.
And I think evangelism
is one half of that.
And I think some teams,
some smaller DevOps teams,
can't really afford to
do both parts of it.
It's much more about
getting the message out,
and so they focus
more specifically
on the evangelism
component of it.
But I think advocacy is rooted
in that bidirectional thing
whereby we influence
the product teams
and we influence
our communities.
Did that answer your
question [INAUDIBLE]??
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
it does, actually.
MARK MANDEL: I'm curious,
also, to know your thoughts on,
if people listen
to this podcast,
or they've heard other things
about developer relations, what
have been some paths--
or are there paths
that you think
would be great for people
who want to get involved
with developer relations?
Because it seems like a fairly
niche thing in some ways.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
Really interesting insight,
because the practitioner way
of thinking about
it is interesting.
I mean, obviously, we're
hiring practitioners.
Then they may not
come necessarily
with advocacy
skills, but they're
going to want to want
to do that kind of work.
And when you interview
people and you ask them
why develop
relations, it's always
about showing people
how things work.
I like teaching people.
I've always been like that.
You find that you
look at their GitHub,
and it's all based
on tutorials and such
like where they've been
producing tutorials to show
people how to do things.
And it's really interesting.
Some people have the
mindset that I just
want to help people.
Some people, also, once they've
experienced pain in the past--
and I don't mean physical
pain, but the pain
that I experienced
at Sun Microsystems
when I was trying
to make something
called OpenSolaris, which was an
open source version of Solaris,
work with all of the Linux
applications and RPMs
and such like that
were out there.
And nothing ever worked.
I would spend a lot
of my time googling
for esoteric error messages.
And nobody's ever seen
this problem before, ever.
So I felt very much that I
wanted to blog about that.
And I wanted to share
that with people
so that they could find it.
If they ever hit that
same problem again,
they would be able to solve it.
And every time that
happened, I blogged about it,
I blogged about it,
I blogged about it.
And I think that's something
that a lot of people
like doing, is like
they don't want
people to experience
the same kind of pain
that they've experienced.
And so that's another reason
to come into this kind of role.
You want to make the
world a better place.
I used to have my tagline for
Twitter was, make the cloud
a better place for developers.
So I think some people
just want to do that.
The question was more about
paths into advocacy, right?
But I think you need
that part of it.
You need that mentality.
You've seen the best speakers.
You know, they're the
ones that actually
really care and do have
empathy for their audience.
And that's always
going to be the case--
having empathy, not
developing necessarily
all that is possible.
Having empathy for
your developers
is also key-- or
your target audience.
I'm overloading that
word "developers" again,
which happens all the
time here currently.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Where would you want
to see this field grow into?
How do you want to
see it evolve, based
on what you've seen so far?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, that's a
really interesting question.
I'll have to give
that some thought.
I want it to be bigger.
I like the fact
that it's different,
that people do it differently
and people approach it
differently.
I like it to be
continuously evolving.
I don't think there's enough
standardization around it.
I would like to see it moving
away from being a marketing
function, which it often is.
I don't think that that's
the best place for DevRel.
I would much rather
see it rooted
in engineering principles.
I know that's not
always possible.
I'm not sure if I have a
strong opinion of that, though.
I don't know if I have a
strong opinion of where
I want it to go.
I want us to have influence.
And I want, really,
effectively, the world
to be a better place for
people who are building tech
or doing tech.
And I think tech is
on a path that makes
it very hard for us to keep up.
It's likely to be asymptotic.
The closer we get to having
really good experiences
for people using
tech is probably--
the further away from us it
gets makes it more difficult.
MELANIE WARRICK: Through
your experience, your history
of working in tech, I'm just
curious as a side thing, what
is one of the technologies that
you've seen that really you
were so excited about
when it finally came,
and you felt like it
completely had this huge impact
that you wouldn't have
imagined or expected?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
I think I've already
mentioned it-- container
scheduling communities.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh.
MANDY WAITE: Docker was--
I watched Solomon Hykes
giving a talk at dotScale--
which is happening in Paris
next week, and I will there--
watching Solomon Hykes
talk about Docker in 2013
was really, really exciting.
And the comparison to
containers, shipping containers
and such like, it
just really moved me.
It was really fantastic.
It was great event, actually.
And having containers
was great, but having
that ability to schedule them,
like the way we do at Google,
was even better for me.
It was, like, I really get this.
I really do understand
how this works.
And I really want to
make this a thing.
I became very determined
to make it a thing.
And hopefully, I made some
small contribution to that.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know you did.
MANDY WAITE: Kubernetes
was very much
the thing that made me
most excited-- these kind
of paradigm shifts.
Although on the
whole, I probably
would say cloud-native
generally.
The whole principles
behind cloud-native
are probably more important
as Kubernetes becomes
more of the new infrastructure
that kind of bubbles down
into the substrate, as I used
to describe it to people.
And things get
built on top of it,
because it's an
enabler for new things.
I think we can do services
better now that we have things
like Istio and other
things like that that
are coming on-- service
messages generally.
And all of the [INAUDIBLE]
system components
that are coming up
around Kubernetes
is just really, really exciting.
And I think it just changes
the way we think about it.
I'd love to get away from
traditional infrastructure
completely and just
be using containers
and not worry about
where they run.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Are we hiring at the moment?
MANDY WAITE: I think DevRel
is very large at Google.
And we have lots
of opportunities
to hire people here.
There's always some
job description,
I think, for a role
within DevRel at Google.
My team, we have a
couple currently.
They're coming and
going and such like.
We have pipelines that
get full up and such like.
But yeah, we're
definitely hiring--
cloud, advocate for
DevOps, potentially,
or cloud advocate
for cloud-native,
that kind of thing.
Really the best place to go
for information around that
is careers.google.com, which
has all of our listings there.
You can also DM me on Twitter.
Is my Twitter handle
going to be published?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we will
definitely be publishing that.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so you can
also DM me on Twitter as well,
and I'll do my best to answer.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I can say,
is it's a pretty great team.
Can't complain too much.
MANDY WAITE: It is a
pretty great team, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
it definitely is.
So, Mandy, I know we're
getting close to time,
but is there any place you're
going to be at outside of Paris
that you'll be
speaking at, or you'll
be attending that you want
people to come and say hi?
MANDY WAITE: Let me think.
Not really.
I don't give so many talks
anymore, which is a shame.
I liked giving talks.
So I don't have any
specific planned.
I'm going to be at
various different events--
Cloud Next events, Cloud Summit
events that we have coming up.
I'll be in London,
probably in Tokyo as well.
Certainly be in the
San Francisco event
that we have in July, which
is July 23, I believe--
Cloud Next in San Francisco.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, definitely.
Anything else that
you want to just share
around developer relations
that we didn't already cover?
MANDY WAITE: I don't think so.
I think drink lots
of water to make
sure your voice can hold up
for long periods of time,
because my voice just
doesn't hold up very well.
You'll always find me in
videos with a bottle of water
in my hand.
So it's very hard with my
voice to survive a long talk.
But that's my big tip is
always have a bottle of water
with you.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like that.
Well, we appreciate you
coming on the podcast.
Thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts on developer
relations.
And, yeah, thank you.
MANDY WAITE: You're
most welcome.
And thank you for
running the podcast.
It's much appreciated.
It's a great thing to listen to.
And I really, really,
really enjoy it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Our pleasure.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Mandy, always
a pleasure to chat with you.
Thank you so much for
coming on the podcast
and talking to us about your
perspective on developer
relations.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Always insightful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Definitely agree.
And I'm glad we
finally got to it, too,
because I know we've
been trying to get that
into the podcast sooner
rather than later.
So, Mark--
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--what's the question?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so as
you were mentioning before,
May 25th, GDPR came into effect.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's
the General Data Protection
Regulation in the EU.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
But where do I go to
learn more about GDPR
in regards to Google
Cloud Platform,
and the effect it has, and all
the stuff that I need to know?
I am not a lawyer.
MELANIE WARRICK: You are not.
Neither of us are.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
this is regulation
in the EU law on data protection
and privacy for all individuals
within the European Union.
It addresses the export
of personal data outside
of the EU.
So we are including in the
show notes a couple of links
we have around how
information in relation
to Google Cloud and General
Data Protection Regulation.
You know, they've
got some information
around complying with the GDPR.
It may require changes
across your business.
This is just more
general guidelines
to keep in mind when
you're looking at GDPR.
And they've got some
tips and pointers,
especially like product
and feature guides as well.
MARK MANDEL: And
it's worth noting
these guides are both G Suite
and Google Cloud Platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
Yes.
Under both of them,
they'll talk about--
you know, it's great,
especially when
you're using two-step
verification to reduce risk
of unauthorized
access by asking users
for additional
proof of identity,
that it's good to help include
those functionalities when
you're thinking about
this regulation.
But you can check
out the resources
that we're going to provide.
And we're also including a link
that is a data protection fact
sheet for citizens of the EU.
And it gives a nice summary
and pseudo-visualizes
some of the key
rights that now exist
and how to understand them.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So Melanie, where are you going?
What are you doing?
What are you up to?
What's going on?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am going to
be speaking at a joint event
that the Women in Machine
Learning and Data Science
and PyLadies have organized
in San Francisco at DoorDash
on Paths to Data
Science on June 26.
And once the meetup
invite is out,
I will definitely include
that in our show notes.
But, yeah, that's
where I'm going to be.
And, Mark, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: So literally,
the day that this comes out,
I will be presenting that
evening at the monthly SF
Game and Developer community.
I'll be doing my presentation
called, "You Can't Just
Add More Servers," which is
the point where you normally
make fun of my accent.
MELANIE WARRICK: I was going to
say, you love saying that, too.
You just "cahn't".
MARK MANDEL: No, actually,
that's just how I talk.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: No,
you like saying that.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
But I'll also highlight, I've
been streaming a lot on Twitch
as well.
I had a really fun one recently
where I did a bunch of stuff.
I'll put a link to
the YouTube video,
actually, because
that'll hang around.
But I've been
streaming [INAUDIBLE]..
I had a fun one recently
where we did some fun work
around wrapping an existing
dedicated game server.
Basically, we took
an existing process,
and then we intercepted
the standard out.
And then using the text that was
coming out of the standard out,
we just implemented
some actions to occur.
It was a really nice
sort of exploration
of interfaces in Go, actually.
I think it worked really nicely.
It was cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: It was cool.
So I'll just highlight
that, because I
thought that was a
particularly nifty one.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
glad you're having fun
with Twitch and the streaming.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's awesome.
Well, Mark, I think that's
it for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Melanie.
Thank you very
much for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]